joining me today is a fellow at the
manhattan institute a self-described
secular conservative and the author of
the diversity delusion
heather mcdonald finally welcome to the
reuben report
i'm so grateful to be here thank you so
much dave i don't know how this hasn't
happened already how did we not you're
on the road all the time you're a hard
man to connect with
we've been on the road together we did
berkeley together and we survived
surprisingly uh attentive and polite
crowd
uh kind of a disappointment actually you
know
we had dinner before and we were like oh
you know it'll be fine if we get some
protest because there's a nice amount of
protesters where it can be enjoyable
then there's like the circus amount
where it's not fun anymore but we were
kind of like oh we'll get some we got a
few but nothing
nothing much and of course they're so
stupid they don't realize that in
protesting somebody they're just
increasing the visibility so
if they really want to destroy all all
uh conservative opposition they should
just
stay quiet you know and let us fade into
the woodwork on that note we'll spend
the next hour trying to gin up some
opposition
to your ideas let's do it okay so first
off
uh i came to know about you when you
spoke or you were to speak at claremont
mckenna university
back in 2017 and you were going to give
a talk on black lives matter
and why don't you just tell the people
what happened because that was the first
time i i found out who you
are well i was going to talk about the
fact that there is enormous
support for the police in minority
communities
i've spent a lot of time in police
community meetings in harlem in south
central l.a
and for what i hear from those good
people is that we want more cops
we want the drug dealers off the corner
i smell pot in my corridor why can't you
do something about it
there's kids hanging out fighting
whatever happened to truancy and
loitering laws
uh and so i was going to present a
different narrative from the black lives
matter narrative
a few days before my uh scheduled talk
a call went out on facebook to shut the
fascist white supremacist homophobe
queerful muslim folk
down we will not allow the fascist
racist
mcdonald to have a platform so
initially they thought they'd move the
venue because where i was speaking had
too many plate glass windows
they decided to keep it in what's called
the athenaeum
but i was put into what was essentially
a safe house on campus waiting for my
talk i could hear the drumming and the
chanting grow louder and louder i
couldn't see what was going on it was a
disconcerting
experience and i was escorted into the
room
with a police escort through a hidden
tunnel i did not know at the time that
about 200 students had surrounded the
building
to prevent anybody from entering to
attend the talk so i spoke to an empty
room
the police were inside the building at
some point they decided that
they couldn't guarantee my safety any
longer because people were pounding on
the plate glass windows
so i was taken out through the kitchen
with police escort into a waiting police
car and
zipped away so i ask you this not
because i know you don't want to play
the vic no i don't i really don't
but it's but i think it's important for
people to realize that this has happened
to so many people who i know
including me and actually i'm very proud
to say that i spoke at claremont mckenna
a few months after
in that in that very room and they made
it very
clear that the whole point of the night
was that they never wanted
what happened to you to repeat again so
they actually did do
what a university is supposed to do but
just can you tell me i mean
you strike me as a totally lovely
pleasant person
that that that people have conception
that people have the they just make up
what you think and that then you're
treated like this it's just not
fun right i mean no it's not fun you
know it really is something because we
can joke about it like oh we love it and
protests are from you know whatever but
well with mobs you don't know what's
going to happen next
and again i am so reluctant to say
anything that can be
attributed to a victim ideology because
that is
used against me but i did have a remote
sense of what it feels like
what felt like to be in the french
revolution and hearing the mob
because people in crowds can become
completely irrational
so you know i i don't know that they're
making up
who i am because i well
i certainly am not against black lives
but my message to them
as they understand it is tantamount
uh to being against black people and and
what
what this the groundwork for this insane
delusion that is used against speakers
is an
even crazier idea which is that students
on college campuses today
are at literal threat of their lives
from circumambient racism and sexism
this is a a delusional idea that is put
into
these students heads sort of k
through 12 because the identity politics
is happening sooner and sooner
but it is certainly reinforced by
diversity bureaucrats
on campus that are in a co-dependent
relationship
with these narcissistic students who
want to elevate their status into the
top dog victim on campus
you know it's funny i did a talk at
university of new hampshire and
protesters were screaming at me in the
middle and disrupting me and they have
no problem using their free speech to
infringe on your free speech of course
um and one of somebody started screaming
that we could be killed when we walk out
of here
exactly i thought we're in the middle of
new hampshire nobody's getting killed
when you walk out of here and certainly
if you don't
behave in any criminal behavior
absolutely nothing is
but they've concocted a story in their
mind and it's very hard
to deconstruct a story for these people
isn't it
yeah i guess so because again we're in a
very weird position in our culture
generally where
the classical virtues venerated strength
and accomplishment perhaps to a fault
you know because you had warrior
cultures and for for centuries
the main calling for males for
accomplishment
was war but the classical virtues
again celebrated heroism we now are in a
very strange position in this culture
where we
venerate victims and so if you can
arrogate to yourself
some victim status and certainly the
burgeoning category of
gender identity is a mark of these
students desperate to find one
final way of being transgressive that
will not be immediately
assimilated into a new diversity
cinecure
uh but they are there's no way they're
going to give up
that sacred a rarified status of victim
and again there's nothing more
tolerant than an american college campus
if if you're not
challenging the orthodoxy but this is
the most tolerant environment in human
history
for society's traditionally marginalized
groups it actively
celebrates those traits that can still
get you stoned or killed elsewhere
so to think you know as brown students
said
occupying the president's office well it
was hard for them to go to classes
because they were focused so hard on
staying alive at brown
it's similar to new hampshire i mean
yeah this is this is
certifiably insane thinking yeah and
unfortunately there aren't enough
brave professors right to push back on
this and then it becomes this
self-fulfilling thing
because then the teachers start feeding
into it and the whole other thing so
before we go too deep on that and i want
to i want to do all your greatest hits
here because you have
you have no fear talking about really
what i think are the hot button issues
of the day
but you describe yourself as a secular
conservative and that is not a phrase
that i hear very often
and as i've you know as i come from the
left
and i still consider myself liberal as
i've been more embraced by say
conservatives
um a lot of people that knew me from way
back when they'll go ah but ruben
they're they're just waiting to turn on
you because they're
they're really religious they don't
really like the gays and whatever else
um so can you sort of describe how you
came to a place that you describe
yourself as a secular
conservative because i don't think
people really think that exists well i
guess i was always secular i wasn't
always conservative
um so what does secular mean to you
first off i'm very
unreligious i am i'm to be honest
probably
um perhaps too fanatically unreligious
i i simply do not
agree with the idea that were
overseen by a personal loving god i find
petitionary prayer
a completely narcissistic activity that
anybody would dare
think that a personal god would care
about
his cancer when there are people being
mowed down in earthquakes
and landslides what i call the daily
slaughter of the innocents
again on a daily basis so
i grew up not in a religious environment
and never even really thought about
religion to me it's an interesting i can
retroactively look at my experience
growing up and
and be sort of amazed at it it is a
verification of what religious people
talk about with the
bi-coastal elites because i grew up in
l.a
i went to a lot of schooling in the east
coast so i was in kind of a liberality
culture
i don't recall knowing anybody who was
religious
until i came to new york in the 90s and
started thinking of myself realizing
that i was conservative
because i'd always been a liberal by
default and in that environment
especially with national review i
started meeting religious people for the
first time
uh what did what did they make of a
secular concern even if you were
liberal in a classical sense but let's
say a burgeoning conservative at that
point what did they make of a secular
person
well i guess my first piece about this
was was for the american conservative
and i just wrote a piece saying you know
the republicans and conservatives who
are so closely
yoking conservative ideology with
religious belief
are making a mistake because i know a
lot of very smart conservatives who are
not themselves believers
either and to say that the only way you
can be moral
is to believe in god uh i think is a
mistake so
i've then had participated founded in a
blog called secular right that was
founded by razeeb khan and
and others uh and i never was
i was never a pariah or drummed out of
the
movement at all i got some sort of
uh sarcastic comments from major figures
like
so how's that atheist is something going
heather right um
but i i can't say that i was ever really
uh
punished for it but i think i was
regarded as a
uh a curiosity yeah so obviously we're
going to talk about so much of what's
wrong with
the post-modern left and the
progressives but let's just talk a
little bit about what's going on
with the right these days or you know
broadly let's say the conservatives the
old school liberals
the libertarians the rest of it i'm
finding it to be the center right let's
say an extremely
open group of people who are really
willing to do this
dive into ideas and and agree to
disagree and all of that
have you always found it to be that way
well again i have i mean i know you're
saying you got a little bit of pushback
let's say or
some joking about people yeah that's
just joking it was not malicious
and it was not really serious um yes
i guess so again i've i'm i consider
myself kind of a latecomer to the right
uh but i
i don't think it was ever closed-minded
i think it's now maybe more
self-consciously opened just because of
the
growing totalitarianism on the left so
perhaps people are extra careful
to uh you know make sure that they're
not excluding anybody but
but i don't i think if you're trying to
push back against some kind of
stereotype that the right is a bunch of
of uh closed-minded bigots i've never
experienced
that i i just don't see it anywhere
right it's actually quite
staggering to me um okay so let's let's
just plow through a whole bunch of
topics so we touched a little bit on
policing already yeah and the black
community is there anything else you
wanted to add to that generally
well just the black lives matter uh met
black lives matter narratives false
end stop we are not living through an
epidemic of racially biased police
shootings
of black men the core flaw of any
left-wing
anti-cop rhetoric or
the mass incarceration meme is the
failure
to find the proper benchmark for
evaluating police behavior
inevitably policing is compared to
population ratios so
let's say in new york city uh about
50 percent of all pedestrian stops are
of blacks
blacks are about 23 percent of the
population a black lives matter activist
or an academic often would say that
shows the police a racist
wrong benchmark the benchmark is crime
policing is crime driven blacks in new
york city commit
71 percent of all shootings if you add
hispanic shootings to black shootings
you account for 98
of all shootings in new york whites are
34 of the population they commit two
percent of shootings so
so that's the basic fallacy that and and
this is a broader problem
right so what would you say is the root
of that the root of this is that
i think the core difference between a
liberal
outlook on the world and a conservative
one is that liberals will only accept
structural explanations for
socio-economic disparities
they will not ever accept a behavioral
explanation that there are
behaviors cultures that are different
that explain poverty rates say
conservatives
maybe to a fault are not particularly
open to
structural explanations and we'll see
behavioral
reasons so for instance when you look at
poverty the biggest driver
in american poverty today is having
children out of wedlock
if you are a single mother uh the
chances are really high
that you're gonna be poor and your child
is about five times more likely to be
poor than
if he were a child of married parents um
and there's a whole set of choices
for good or bad that people can make
that
almost guarantee that you can become
middle class
it's very simple three simple things you
can do
graduate from high school wait until
you're married to have a child and work
at a job full-time
any job low minimum wage job 73
of people who do that are not poor so
that to me is the basic difference so
the benchmark problem in policing
comes from not being willing to look at
behavior
and and i think that is true for
everything
in in society we have the most dangerous
conceit out there is this disparate
impact analysis
that says that any neutral policy that
has a disparate impact on racial groups
must be biased again that is a analysis
that only makes sense if you don't look
at behavior
so why do certain narratives then
get sold much more than other narratives
i have my own theories on this but
why is the narrative out there that the
police are racist i mean
did the media all collude to decide the
same thing and put it out there i mean
really how does
how do those how do those bad ideas then
spread well one thing i don't think is
happening i always get us is this all
soros
i don't think it is everybody wants
human beings like want agency right we
want one answer they want one answer and
they want to believe that
everything is like from top down i don't
think it source money
but i think there are memes that spread
and i think there are ideologies
and i think that american culture now
is very uncomfortable
with inner city culture with
a certain dysfunctional minority culture
and doesn't
don't want to talk about it we want to
turn our eyes away from it
and we have the most appalling history
of racism in this country it is
really unthinkable how blind we were to
the
profound hypocrisy that governed so much
of our polity for so long
you know one when can't begin to
understand how how that could not have
been obvious
but i think our degree of guilt
for that is now so great and and
understandable frankly
that we're very reluctant to ascribe
agency
to blacks we want to say everything the
continuing problems the failure to
close the achievement gap the crime
disparities which are massive the
victimization disparities blacks die of
homicide
at six times the rate of whites and
hispanics combined
that's a civil rights problem but nobody
wants to talk about that
instead we want to change the narrative
to be it's all white racism
which is a way of infantilizing blacks
of saying there's nothing
you can do for yourselves of getting rid
of the acting white culture
you know emulate we should all emulate
asians
i've i pose a thought experiment if
blacks acted like asians for 10 years
in all things the same like negligible
rate of out of wedlock child rearing
the same fanatical involvement in
schools
you know drive parental drive study
you're going to go to harvard you know
nothing else is acceptable
don't worry you may not go to harvard if
you're able these drives that's right
well you're going to have to be ten
times greater than any better than
anybody else to go to harvard and you
will be
right if if if the behaviors were the
same
and we still saw these socio-economic
disparities
then i will entertain institutional
structural racism and as
an explanation but as long as the
behaviors are so vastly different
in in california where we are now
the truancy rate for blacks is five
times higher than any other ethnic group
as long as those behaviors are so
different i think it's premature
to say the only possible explanation is
structural racism
do you think this is also that we just
have this sort of self-fulfilling
prophecy now between the media
and our politicians so like right as
we're taping this right now the
la school teachers are on strike and
it's like well wait a minute
i see all these lefties on twitter
everyone complaining and teachers need
more money and blah blah
except it's all progressives that run
california and la forever
so it's like these are your guys that
have been putting in all these policies
that the teachers are upset by the
but it's that they just the answer is
always easy it's just more money more
money more money more money
and that and that makes people feel good
because it's always easy to say oh we'll
just give it more money
and then the media does the same thing
too where it's just it's racism
it needs more money and that there's no
actual
well there's substantive debate it's
happening online now but not sort of in
the places that it should happen
do you see politicians having these
discussions honestly
anywhere or well no i mean i think again
nobody wants to talk about individual
agency
nobody wants to talk about its
behavioral choices and you know this
gets to something we've briefly touched
on before which is the debate around
tucker carlson and and him it was a very
odd moment i mean i
i love tucker but he's taking basically
a left-wing position
which is that you know the plight of
rural america or the opioid crisis
the the disengagement of males from the
workforce
uh which is a very serious thing is a
result of economic policy
and there's been people who've been
pushing back against that on national
view david french
yeah this is just in the last 10 days
right and i think a
persuasive way which is to say well
you're doing the same kind of
uh shift of responsibilities as
traditionally the left does which is to
say well it's these large social forces
no well actually again even if
we've got jobs moving off offshore
there still are individual choices that
people can make
that vastly increase their chances of
success
again do not have children out of
wedlock
study do not get involved in drugs don't
become a pothead
these are all within individual agency
obviously the left doesn't want to
acknowledge that because
there is some sort of interest in
expanding
bureaucracies to deal with dysfunction i
mean i've seen this i've written a lot
about
hispanics in california and spent time
in
the berendo school in pico rivera middle
school
which is just crawling with gang
counselors and pregnancy counselors for
the social
dysfunction that's happening with the
second third generation hispanics but
the bureaucracy grows larger and larger
every place
uh as a substitute for saying to
individuals
you know pull up your bootstraps and you
can do it yourself yeah there's an odd
thing where then the conservatives and
the libertarians who are against
authoritarianism by nature
need a little bit of authoritarian
structure
so to speak i had catherine burble
singing here who's a
school administrator in the uk who's
taking she uh
she was a teacher in the inner city in
london and she realized how
dysfunctional everything that you're
talking about was and the breakdown of
the family and these kids
they were malnutritioned and they had no
they behaved horribly and all these
things
and now she started her own school the
michaela school and i went there
and these kids in in between classes
they have to walk exactly in line they
can't speak
during lunch they can only talk about
one topic and there's a you know anyone
could be called on any given moment
and i thought this is so bizarre because
here this is the right kind of
authoritarianism
exactly i thought that that's actually
pretty cool you got to get them young
though
right right structure i mean this is
there's charter schools in the united
states like kip
that do the same thing you know
everything is scripted
because the families are so
dysfunctional now again predominantly
single mothers although there's
obviously
let me just put in the disclaimer there
are heroic single mothers out there who
are doing the right thing by their
children but
i'm sorry on average i'm not talking
about you individual i'm talking on
average you're it's the
worst thing you could do for your kid
not to have the father at the home
but yes this is the last chance these
kids have to get socialized
and the tragedy again to bring back to
the disparate impact
idea something that we've just been
going through with
with trump's education secretary the
obama administration had this idea
that was already bubbling on the
progressive left in education schools
that
if black kids are disciplined more than
white kids that
must be because of teacher racism again
you are not allowed to look at behavior
this is the key the left will never look
at behavior
and so the fact that black kids commit
homicide at 10 times the rate black
teenagers between the ages of 14 and 17
commit homicide at 10 times the rate
of white and hispanic male teens
combined according to federal data
on homicide which is the gold standard i
mean there's there's nothing
you know at all a wiggle room in this
data
that type of disparity in socialization
that leads to those types of
homicide disparities shows up in the
classroom as well as any inner city kid
can tell you
the obama rule said you may not
discipline
black kids more and as a result
kids are running a muck in schools
they're attacking their team so
basically you just put these arbitrary
rules in that
clearly don't fit what is actually
happening but it makes you feel good
it makes you blame whites everything
it's all the product of white racism
so so yes i'm all for informal structure
if if a family cannot do it i mean
aristotle again this gets back to the
secular right thing i i hear that
people say well how do you raise a moral
kid without religion
aristotle said virtue is habit
and i i don't know i was not raised in a
religious family but is it
really the case that a parent says to
his five-year-old son don't hit your
three-year-old brother because jesus
said not to
or is it just do not hit your your
three-year-old brother
you know i think the authority from
parental authority
is sufficient and you acclimate
children to a set of behaviors that are
self-controlling deferring gratification
by just teaching this is how we behave
and through the inculcation of habit i i
don't think
in raising children i i just can't
imagine
at what point you need to invoke the ten
commandments i think that a lot of these
behaviors
the golden rule is something that kant
talked about as something that is pretty
innate to a understanding that humans
develop of
what is needed to function in a
relatively
civil society yeah i have to tell you
this is such an example of why i love
doing this show because just an hour
before sitting down with you i don't
know if you know him but i had dr
everett piperon who's the president
of oklahoma wesleyan university and you
guys
probably agree on politics at like 99
and yet he's religious and a lot of what
we talked about was from a religious
perspective
but that to me is that that's the beauty
of what america is all about it's like
actually on the things that that matter
outside of what your personal beliefs
are
you're agreeing on all this stuff and
then you have some differences on
existential questions and
yeah so be it well and and it's also
something that we're
now playing with fire of being able to
disagree amicably
i mean i i don't know if we should all
be like
screaming you know send in the the fire
alarm or the the fire trucks
but this growing civil violence that is
predominantly on the left obviously
charlottesville was an abomination
but i would say in terms of sheer
numbers of incidents
obviously the the right the alt-right
the crazies took a life which
is a game changer i mean that's
qualitatively different than anything
than
you know following around tucker carlson
or screaming at trump officials
nevertheless uh the anti-fa violence
is is playing with tribal hatreds
in a way that i think is extremely naive
if we think that america is permanently
immune
from the type of violence that still
characterizes other societies yeah and
no
buddy on the left seems to no well first
off cnn ignores it basically and then
the politicians don't say anything about
it
okay so let's let's link this to one of
the other things that you talk about a
lot which is sort of what's happening
right
now very very intensely which seems like
this new war on men
or war on boys so how how is this
related
to to it's related sort of in in a
racial context especially if you're
talking about young black men
but we can we can separate those two
things a little bit if you want well
females are determined to think of
themselves as victims too
uh which is preposterous there is not a
single mainstream institution
in the society whether it's a university
a bank a law firm a government agency
a foundation k through 12
that is not well k-12 probably not
because there you've got a super
abundance of females but
but every mainstream institution is
trying to hire and promote as many
females as possible
i know for sure i just it is just
inevitable
that i have been the so-called
beneficiary of gender preferences
continuously you know there's a there's
now it's good to admit it doesn't it
you know no it disgusts me frankly uh
you know there's now this whole meme
about mantles
uh thou shalt not put together a
scientific panel
of the top cancer researchers
if it happens to be all males you must
put
females on that panel this is crazy who
cares
i really do not care who solves
alzheimer's
if it's all females because they're the
best so be it but if it's all males
i don't give a damn are you telling me
that if you had heart surgery you would
want
i got to check out i would want the best
surgeon regardless of their sexuality or
gender or skin color what kind of bigot
are you
i don't know i i guess i'm just blind to
the travails of females you know
and and look at again females now or at
at least at parity it's very curious
all the institutions that have a super
abundance of females
nobody ever thinks to say well there
must be anti-male bias
you know but well that's anything
and it's also the case you know in um
academia if anybody says well
there's these vast disparities of
liberals to conservatives and academia
which i frankly
think is kind of a side issue i david
horowitz yes
david horowitz tells a story about going
to colombia in the 1950s and being
taught by marxists
but it didn't matter because mostly
politics stayed out of the classroom but
they were open-minded
and my ideal of education is frankly a
pure ivory tower i think everybody
should just be reading
edmund spencer's the fairy queen and
milton and trollope
and wallowing in pastoral poetry i think
i shouldn't be even
i don't think i should be invited to a
college campus because me talking about
policing
is is of the wisps of of the
of transitory reality that they'll get
to there's time enough after you
graduate
these are four precious years to take a
deep dive into beauty
into grandeur into sublimity and to wit
and to irony
into the greatest expressions of mankind
not into
contemporary politics or homeless
politics or whatnot but that's
obviously highly unlikely to happen
that that's fascinating to me because i
guess i agree with the premise that i
wish college could be that
thing and then on the other hand when i
go to these schools and i see so many
kids engaged in the things that we're
talking about i i always leave
incredibly inspired because i'm like oh
you guys are
at least awake to these issues but i see
your point it's like if they could be
in a weird way if they could be
insulated from them a little bit to get
to deeper learning
of the foundational things maybe that
would be better but yes aristotle and
kant and shakespeare
and milton's comas i mean language that
is so sensual that is
just of of almost terrifying eroticism
they're not going to come across this
later
uh and so i'm grateful to the fact that
when i was in college
i was a acolyte of deconstruction alas
i spent way too much time trying to plow
my throat
my way through la mitolegi blanche by
jacques and
you know reading la khan and paul damon
which was a grotesque waste of time but
multiculturalism hadn't hit yet so i was
in college
in the 70s so we read the canon
without anybody thinking to complain
about gonads and melanin
so i could i could read the best
literature right who cares it didn't
come up
it's amazing now you'd think that oh
this is the first
thing you ask about a book you know well
do i see myself reflected there
no okay therefore i'm not going to read
it you know please do not expose me to
a writer that is going to take me out of
myself which is something the
renaissance humanist
craved and yearned for so anyway
the whole gender thing the mantles there
was a
the past president of the american
physics society
put out a call to members to
nominate for physics prizes and to put
on panels females
just the most egregious blatant
discarding
of a meritocratic principle something
that is irrelevant to physics
so this is everywhere uh and i just
reject it completely and the campus idea
that females are at risk of rape culture
on campus
is equally ludicrous if if these
statistics that
the campus rape industry have been
throwing around
for the last 10 15 20 years
were remotely accurate one to four to
one to five females
sexually assaulted during their time on
campus that is a crime rate that is
unseen around the globe
detroit is our most violent city
all four of the fbi's violent index
felonies which is
murder rape aggravated assault and
robbery
you put all of those together you get a
two percent
violent crime rate rape is like
.1 of the population
now obviously the campus thing is over
four years even so
you you can never you cannot possibly
get to one in four to one five
if that were the case we would have seen
a mass
exodus of females from coed
universities decades ago these highly
sophisticated mothers
who were right now in manhattan paying
200 an hour
to prep their girl tots to get into the
most
prestigious pre-k to set them on the
path to some ivy league they would be
demanding single sex
education you would not see on every
saturday night
the girls at uva trooping down rugby
road to the frats
unless girls are stupid and they do not
they're not strong women together and
there's rape going on and they're not
warning each other which i'm willing to
entertain that as an explanation
but what i'm not willing to entertain is
the explanation that there is a
epidemic of sexual assault and females
are simply
like i don't know they're accepting it
or something it's just it's very bizarre
so what do you make of how as the
intersectional pyramid that is
yeah you know based on these varying
levels of what i would say or perceived
depression not say real oppression
that they constantly are talking about
racism and bigotry and yet they seem to
be the ones enforcing it so i think the
best example of this
is what's happened over the last couple
months with the women's march where it
became very clear
that many of the leaders were either
anti-semites themselves
or seriously embracing of anti-semites
and yet these are the same people who
would tell you that
you know everyone else is a bigot and a
racist and the rest of it
i guess this is just the natural outcome
of this well it's hilarious i love it i
mean i
i love the internecine struggles
on the left right it's right it's a
comedy actually
and i always wonder you know when act
leftists get called out
for bigotry or racism does it make him
ever think
well gee you know i've been calling
everybody else a racist
i know i'm not these are false claims
maybe the other people the conservatives
aren't as well you know so
i don't know if the new york times has
called out or even
people who i really respect i mean
nicholas christakis at yale
he's a he's a wonderful serious scholar
but he is a man of the left
you know and and even after he almost
got eaten by this monster right so he
was mobbed for three hours by students
cursing at him in the most
vile language it's just the most
shocking instantiation of the cultural
revolution of these
students that have been just fed their
victimology for for the last 16 years
and nobody
daring to expect of them civil behavior
i hope i totally get this right but at
this moment where these kids are
screaming at him at yale
one of the girls screaming at him
screams who hired you and it turns out
that she
was on the board that helped hire him
that's how bananas the whole thing is
right right um but shouting you know you
are disgusting and it just
it was unbelievable but he even after
this happened
it's sort of unfortunate he penned a
missive to the student body
still wanting to confirm his progressive
bona fides and saying well of course i
understand that
for minority students at yale you know
this is a struggle
which is bs no no student
no student at yale is in a struggle for
psychological
safety or anti-haven from racism
yale again it is the most progressive
environment in human history so
so you know what we've seen with brett
weinstein and and whatnot they now
are realizing they're making broader uh
affiliations
yeah well it's funny i bring when i do
stand up now i usually bring one of the
idw crew with me you should you should
join me for one of them
but i bring brett on several times and
most of my audience now is libertarian
or conservative or old school liberal
and he still describes himself as a
progressive and they love him
and and even though there's a there's an
absolute disagreement on plenty of the
issues and we get into all of it from
climate change to everything else
the audience cheers and applauds them
and i always tell them i go bro you know
you do know that we couldn't get five
progressives to show up anywhere for us
right so that does tell you something
yeah about about the tolerant crew
uh all right moving on from hot button
to hot button
because we're in a little bit of a time
issue with you today um let's talk about
immigration because this is obviously
the
thing at the moment what is your stance
on immigration
well i think low-skilled mass
immigration is not a good thing for this
country
i think it's absolutely a country's
prerogative to define who comes into the
country
it is not for people outside of the
country to make a de facto immigration
policy
by their decisions to come into the
country illegally
and uh you know the left will not
talk about the effect on americans wages
it's it's quite bizarre you know cesar
chavez the farmworker organizer was
completely against illegal immigration
because he realized that it undercuts
the wages of
of of american hispanics and blacks
barbara jordan a black congressman in 94
chaired an
immigration panel totally against the
levels of low-skilled immigration we had
saying it's
it's affecting america's working classes
the hardest
and i think that we're bringing in a
culture that is
not in our current environment with its
monolithic
flows from the central america and
mexico
it's not assimilating and what i've been
reporting on uh for a decade now
is the downward assimilation of the
second third generation of hispanics
into an underclass culture you know the
conservative happy face narrative is
hispanic family values well hispanics
have the second highest
out of wedlock child wearing bait after
black blacks it's about
71 percent of all black children are
born to single parents with hispanics is
53 percent
that's really high when daniel patrick
moynihan wrote his extraordinarily
present
uh alarm about black family breakdown in
1965 and he said
as long as so many black boys are being
raised without fathers
we are not going to close the economic
gap
we are not going to make further
progress on civil rights because
these boys are not being socialized
at that point the black out of wedlock
birth rate
was 23 percent moynihan thought that was
a crisis
right now it's 71 percent for blacks for
hispanics it's twice that
i'll never take a an opportunity not to
discuss daniel patrick moynihan for a
second but
so where are the good liberals on this
are they just gone or
is it what you just referred to before
which is they know what happens when
they've called everyone else racist for
so long so then they just
tower away and disappear i mean i
suspect it's some version of that
because i've kind of lived through it
myself
where are they on this being immigration
or on out of what like the family breaks
well
on almost everything we've discussed
here so far where are the where are the
good
liberals of today well again they will
not talk about behavior that is that
that is the dividing line
lib moynihan could he could say look at
there our behavioral at this point
from here on out we're going to see
predominantly behavioral not that
obviously in the 60s there was still
just egregious
racism but but it was possible to say
although you know even back then he was
immediately turned into a pariah
so things weren't so great back then it
was just mobbed and he
that that report which could have if it
had been embraced and
brought into the public discourse would
have meant that we weren't here today
uh talking and having to write these
phony narratives
about the fact that we still have this
achievement gap in crime gap and
incarceration gap
uh i don't know i think again i think
people
feel very uncomfortable uh with
the continuing racial divide
and they somehow have lost any
confidence
in saying to blacks you have agency
and it's not all our fault so before we
skew too far off the immigration thing
then
how do we do this conversation right how
do we actually do it right it seems
right like right now as it stands we're
sort of between either
you want a wall and protectionism let's
say or you want
open borders there seems to be very
little in between that even though i
think probably 80
of us if not if not 95 of us want
something that's
much more in between those two things
well i mean
the the bromide as well we need
comprehensive immigration reform
uh you know that that's sort of the safe
harbor that you can say in this
i suppose i mean comprehensive
immigration reform is basically code for
amnesty for daca for the dreamers and
usually
uh higher levels of of a family
and chain low skilled immigration i
i've written for well we also need
e-verify we need to you know have
employers
have to mandatorily check the work
papers which is very easy it's
instantaneous
they do that they get a safe harbor
against any kind of liability but i
i think frankly seeing these caravans
seeing the
the mob storming border patrol throwing
rocks trying to scale the fences
uh i'm in favor of a wall you know the
only reason to oppose a wall is because
you think it works
that's why the liberals don't want it uh
they
you know if they think it's so
superfluous and put it up you know what
the hell
but they actually do uh think it will be
effective and that's why they don't want
it but i think
again we need to have be able to talk
about
uh what low skilled the
fiscal costs that this mass low skilled
poverty culture that we are importing is
imposing
on the american taxpayer whether it's
through schools
you know the all of the again i see this
at the brendo middle school in pika
rivera
all of the councillors trying to get
these kids that are getting sucked into
gang culture
to try and keep them on their feet
the the health care costs you know now
you have
demographic change so much in california
you have california saying we're going
to have
full health care for illegal immigrants
mayor de blasio in new york
full taxpayer substituted health care
for illegal immigrants
if the politics keeps changing this way
that's going to be more and more
and um i don't know you know a lot of
americans some americans understand that
this is just
extraordinarily burdensome on our
society
yeah all right we only have about 10
minutes left okay now
everything everything we've been talking
about is sort of exactly what the
diversity delusion is all about yeah
um but if i had to pick one thing to to
end on here
out of the book what should we go with
here because i could do i could do 20
more topics with you about all of this
but these things are all so
interestingly linked together obviously
well i would say the diversity mania
the the sort of equation of the
diversity mania which is present now
both in universities and abroad outside
of universities
is a race and gender the most important
things about the self
i completely disagree with i can tell
you being female is not an
accomplishment
it is not a particularly interesting
status as far as i'm concerned
uh most important thing about the self
discrimination based on those
characteristics is the defining feature
of american society
see tonight coates the american
academic idol and the idol of the
establishment who says that destroying
the black body
is the very essence of america and third
that any lack of
proportionality of race and gender in
any institution
is by definition the result of sexism
and racism
that idea now it defines university
culture
but it is now spreading into the
sciences that's what i think is the most
concerning and the most amazing
because a lot of optimists the people
who want to see
you know oh this is fine there's all
these firewalls the firewall
whether it's the free market it's
corporations they'll never do this
or it's science the sciences are never
going to be taken care of you know
they'll never be taken over by identity
politics
wrong the national science foundation is
spending
billions of taxpayer dollars funding
gender studies professors
to study intersectionality and
microaggressions in engineering and math
this is insane uh you have
google you know firing engineers who
dare to challenge the feminist orthodoxy
i have worked out i'm collecting a
series of
natural experiments testing the
discrimination hypothesis
when it comes to gender because again we
look at google
and we see 20 percent female engineers
at google and other high-tech firms
the diversity explanation is that's
because google's gatekeepers
are sexist they are simply unable to
spot engineering talent
when it comes with female gonads
so what we need to test the
discrimination hypothesis
are institutions with no gatekeepers
that are
wide open and i'm collecting examples of
these
and what they show is is that there are
natural differences between males and
females when it comes
appetite for competition drive and yes
high-end math skills
wikipedia blind editing
it's open to anybody there are no
gatekeepers anybody can edit or write a
wikipedia
entry let me guess 50 50 men and women
right right what is it come on down 13
females the the female entries are
really weak
nobody's nobody's keeping them out i
noticed this were scrabble championships
nobody's females predominate among
casual uh amateur home scrabble players
there have never been a female scrabble
championship
uh spelling
no that's what the the uh geography bees
the winners are males it goes on and on
and on
history bees the winners are males these
are things without gatekeepers the fact
of this
silicon valley the drive that we see to
create these startups
you guys in the intellectual dark web
are predominantly male
uh that's not that there are not
individual females out there with as
much competitive drive as much
empire building let's take risks
but one of the things that got james
demour fired from google for his
infamous 10-page memo suggesting that
there may be
non-discriminatory reasons for the lack
of 50 50 gender parodied google
he talked about some of the big five
personality traits and he used this
phrase
neuroticism and to the lay ear that
sounded very offensive
and he said females are more neurotic
this is a common term
in psychology this has been around for
decades
that's one of the big five traits right
and it turns out that females
are more risk-averse and they worry more
and there might be biological and
historical reasons for this
yes yeah so it's interesting i'm sure
you know about this but uh
over the last couple months where jordan
and i have been traveling we went to
sweden and now everyone on the left and
all the socialists they always point to
sweden as the place where they're doing
everything right in sweden right and
sweden which is done egalitarianism
right right there's no doubt about it
they have been completely equal men and
women
well now they've found out that for
whatever reason men
still want to be engineers and women
still want to be nurses
right so now they ran the experiment
properly and that they made a truly
egalitarian society
but the post-modernists and the leftists
and the progressives
won't let them take the results of the
experiment that they did
right and now they're trying to rejigger
the society again right
and it's it's just absolutely incredible
it's incredible and again if there's
if there's more females than males in an
institution that's fine and let me just
finish the
you know with the with the with the
conservative to liberal ratio and
academia
if you point that out to to the liberals
in academia that that you know in some
faculties you have a hundred to one
liberal to conservative ratio what they
will say is
well a conservatives are just not
interested in these fields
or they're not as smart explanations
that they will not
accept right for why females gravitate
towards more
hands-on relational human-centered work
and they're
they're just not as interested in
perhaps being coders at 2am with cold
pizza
in some ugly computer science lab
that the geeks the science geeks are
predominantly males and they're probably
on the spectrum
so what get over it who cares big damn
whoop all right you're super busy so i'm
for we're all right we're going to do
this again for sure because i feel like
we just got warmed up here great but
let's end on
give me something positive out of this
for the people that see all this that
are truly worried about it
that are emailing me every day that care
about these conversations what are the
signs that
we might be getting some wins here or
that enough people are starting to wake
up to this craziness
well your audience i think i mean there
really are people out there
the the universities people are
operating under terrified silence
i i hear from professors i hear from
faculty it is unbelievable
yeah it's like stasis it's like it's
like east germany or russia
people are afraid to speak in a
university which purports to be the
model of human discourse
but there are people that are pushing
back against it and all i can say is
we are not going to beat this thing
unless we push back against the
narrative that any disparities in
representation are due to racism and
sexism
as long as that narrative wins the push
for quotas the destruction of scientific
meritocracy
is going to continue and china is going
to end up whooping our ass when it comes
to technological innovation
because when it comes to science they
care about only one thing can you do the
engineering very strange the people who
are obsessed with our differences seem
to want us to be the same more than
anybody else
right very respectful individuality it's
been a prize for heather i'm sorry this
was so quick
we're going to do it again for sure and
for more on heather you can follow her
on twitter
at hmd at mi